protesters gather outside the election
commission building to protest against
what they say are voting irregularities
some people were unable to vote after at
least 1 800 vote counting machines
malfunctioned during national elections
on monday less than two percent of the
total number of machines
we are here because we have seen how
sloppy the election commission's work is
they had three years to prepare for this
election but they are incompetent
they took away the right of filipinos to
vote for what they want
the protesters were soon pushed back by
police with water cannon and swat teams
on standby
the heavy pushback has long been a
hallmark of the outgoing administration
incumbent president rodrigo duterte had
little tolerance for dissent or
criticism
ferdinand marcos jr whose late father
ruled the country for two decades and
was often described as a dictator is on
course to win a landslide victory
and with duterte's daughter sarah set to
become the vice president many are
concerned their civil liberties may
shrink further analysts say the return
to power of the marcos family is the
result of decades of rebranding
boosted in recent years through social
media campaigns often with misleading
information
studies have shown that the marcos
campaign and the marcus family has
usually invested
in this machinery and i think
if they're going to be the next
administration that this is going to be
a lean and mean propaganda
spewing machine
he says the strategy may not only help
them win power but keep it
for marcos supporters gathered outside
his campaign headquarters the day after
the polls those concerns were far from
their minds as their candidate heads for
victory with an unassailable margin
florence louis al jazeera manila
well let's speak now to jamal alan dogen
who's also in manila so
joella we've had a picture of the
capital what about the rest of the
country
well
the philippine military basically just
um requested the commission on elections
to declare 15 villages in the llano del
sur province in the southern region of
mindanao as areas where elections have
failed there have been sporadic violence
across the mindanao region some areas
have known to be considered as election
hot spots and there are reports also
that at least six people have already
been killed there was a standoff also at
the llano capital province so there were
two clans two warring political clans
tried to secure the ballots that were
supposed to be sent over to manila and
that they these ballots had to be
secured by the military so this gives
you a picture of what is happening in
mindanao but although there have been at
least 15 recorded electoral violence
according to the philippine military
this is still small compared to the 2019
midterm elections where they've recorded
more than 50 electoral violence still at
least six people were killed and so
there are ongoing investigations reports
also of you know several officials
getting involved in ballot snatching
strafing um you know election inspectors
getting killed but again the commission
on elections that's basically that
before they could act on investigations
these reports have to be verified here
in the capital manila protests have just
ended we've got supporters of vice
president lanier brother demanding that
the commission on election officials get
out of the building to face him because
they say they find so many
irregularities not just you know um the
breakdown of more than one thousand
eight hundred vote counting machines but
in the way the votes were electronically
temporarily and initially submitted late
monday night now canvassing has again
been delayed by a full day so i guess it
will take a few days before an official
winner will be declared for more for the
more than 18 000 positions across the
country in particular the most
contentious the the pres the the the the
role the next uh president of the
philippines
thanks for that's updated jim adam dugan
there let's take this on further we can
hear now from marietta who's an editor
at large for the media company rappler
and she says there are fears that marcos
presidency will erode democracy in the
philippines
as we've seen during the election
campaign he has the he was the least
open among the candidates he did not
grant
media interviews except to those he
considered friendly
he undermined the mainstream and
independent media by bringing along his
cautery of vloggers
to the campaign he evaded tough
questions so we foresee that when he
becomes president it will be a secretive
office of the president and he will
continue the disinformation that he
started way back many years ago when he
ran for vice president and lost let's
remember that duterte the current
president paved the way
for
a leader who will abide by an autocrat's
playbook duterte started when he
campaigned for president and he became
president used a lot of this information
and we saw that this some of these were
state-sponsored so it's easy for the
successor to continue with this uh
erosion of democracy because duterte has
paved the way so we see this information
we see a weakening of institutions and
thirdly
our standard history textbooks do not
thoroughly discuss martial law and the
abuses of the dictatorship so it's very
very sad that
when marcus
becomes sits down as president on june
30 we may even
lose our history so this is a battle for
our future as well as for our past